[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم زين
العابدين توفيق وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه
تقع احداث وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من البيت
الابيض الذي اعلن نواش ستواصل العمل في
المجال الجوي الدولي وان البحر الاسود لا
يتبع لاحد وذلك بعد تحطم المسيره
الامريكيه متطوره عقب اعتراضها من قبل
مقاتلات روسيه
الرد من موسكو جاء سريعا على اللسان وزير
الدفاع الامريكيه الذي قال مدير الدفاع
الروسي الذي قال ان المقاتلات الروسيه لم
تستخدم اسلحه محموله جوا ولم تتلامس مع
الطائره الامريكيه المسيره
هذه بيروت الليله على وقع التراجع الليره
اللبنانيه الى مستوى قياسي امام الدولار
ليصل الى 100 الف ليره في السوق الموازيع
في مواضيع الحصاد ايضا هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
في تطور غير مسبوق فوق مياه البحر الاسود
واشنطن تعلن تحطم مسيرتنا امريكيه متطوره
بعد اعتراضها من قبل مقاتلات روسيه
يحجم عن الافصاح عن مهمه الطائره وعم اذا
كانت تحمل ذخيره وموسكو تقول ان المسيره
الامريكيه رصدت قرب شبه جزيره القرم متجهه
نحو الحدود الروسيه وسقطت في المياه دون
التعرض لها
القتال في بخمت يتحول الى معركه حياتنا او
موت
بعد اجتماعه بقياده الجيش اتخاذ قرار
بحمايه المدينه واستمرار القتال وملك
الشركه باجنر يقول ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تعد لهجوم المعاكسه
وتزامنا مع اعلان موسكو بلغه انتاج
الذخيره مستوى حاله الحرب بوتم يشدد على
ان الصراع في اوكرانيا هدفه الدفاع عن
وجود روسيا
[موسيقى]
صفقه الغواصات النوويه الامريكيه
البريطانيه الاستراليه تثير حفيظه الصين
تعتبر الصفقه تهديدا للامن العالمي وتساعد
على انتشار الاسلحه النوويه وموسكو تحذر
من تداعيات الدفع البنيه التحتيه الى اسيا
مع تشدد الاشتباكات في لاهور بين انصار
عمران خان الشرطه الباكستانيه خلاف رئيس
حزب انصاف مع الحكومه ياخذ منحا تصاعديا
وزير الداخليه يقول ان الشرطه ستعتقل خان
وستقدمه للعداله ورئيس الحكومه السابق
يطلب من انصاره مواصله التظاهر حتى لو تم
اعتقاله
وفي لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصات
الرقميه ناقشنا سياقه واسباب انهيار
الليره اللبنانيه ووصولها امام الدولار
الامريكي الى مستوى
منخفاض قياسي جديد بلغ سعر صرف الدولار
مئه الف ليره في السوق الموازيه لاستطلاع
ارائكم بشار هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم في اي سياق
ياتي الانهيار الجديد للعمله اللبنانيه
جاءت النتيجه على النحو التالي 10% قالوا
انه ياتي في سياق اضراب المصارف اللبنانيه
نحو 75% قالوا انه ياتي في سياق استمرار
حاله الشلل السياسيه ورجح 15% ان يكون
السياقه هو التعثر خطه التعافي الاقتصاديه
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصات الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
الكيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه الان
لقاؤنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيه ودوليا
[موسيقى]
تابعونا ايضا في الحصاد
غداث مناورات العسكريه الامريكيه الكوريه
الجنوبيه هي الاوسع نطاقا منذ خمس سنوات
كوريا الشماليه تطلق صاروخين بالسين قصيره
للمدى قباله ساحلها الشرقي
السلام عليكم اعلنت قياده القوات
الامريكيه في اوروبا فقدان مسيره من طراز
ام كيو تسعه بعد اصطدام مقاتله الروسيه
بها فوق البحر الاسود وقالت القياده في
بيان ان مقاتلتين روسيتين من طراز سوخوي
سبعه وعشرين قامت بعمليه اعتراض غير امنه
وغير مهنيه للمسيره اوضح البيان ان احدى
المقاتلتين الروسيتين اصطدمت بمروحيه
مسيره الامريكيه ما اجبر القوات الامريكيه
على اسقاطها في المياه الدوليه في البحر
الاسود
واضافت قيره القوات الامريكيه في اوروبا
ان المقاتلتين الروسيتين عمدت مرارا الى
التحليق امام المسيره وافراغ وقود عليها
بطريقه متهوره وغير مهنيه ما يظهر انعدام
الكفاءه والمهنيه وفق البيان
وفي موسكو قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تعليقا على اعلان القوات الامريكيه تصادم
طائره الروسيه مع مسيرات الامريكيه قالت
انها رسلت مسيرتها امريكيه قرب شبه جزيره
القرم تتجه نحو الحدود الروسيه وهي تغلق
نظام التعريف الخاص بها
اوضحت الدفاع الروسيه ان طائراتها
المقاتله لم تستخدم ذخيرتها ولم تتواصل مع
المسيره الامريكيه واضافت ان المسيرات
الامريكيه سقطت بسبب مناوره حاده واصطدمت
بسطح الماء
وبينما اعلنت واشنطن استدعاء السفير
الروسي لديها قال منسق والاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي جون كيربي ان حادثه اصطدام
المسيره الامريكيه بطائره روسيه كانت
نتيجه التصرف متهور وغير امن غير احترافي
من الجانب الروسي حسب وصفه واضاف ان
اعتراض الطائرات الروسيه للطائرات
الاجنبيه فوق البحر الاوسط ليس امرا غير
مالوف واوضح ان المسيره الامريكيه كانت في
المجال الجوي فوق المياه الدوليه ولم تكن
تشكل اي تهديد على اي جهه
اكد كاربي ان الولايات المتحده ستواصل
العمل في البحر الاسود وفقا لما تنص عليه
القوانين الدوليه وانه اذا كانت روسيا
تريد بعث رساله لواشنطن بعدم الطيران فوق
البحر الاسود فان الرساله فشلت حسب تعبيره
انا من موسكو مدير مكتب الجزيره ومن مراسل
الجزيره فادي منصور وابدا بك فادي يعني
مجمل المعطيات التي خرجت من وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه بشان هذه الطائره ومهمتها وكيفيه
اسقاطها لانه حسب ما قرانا في الخبر فان
الذي اسقطها هو الجيش الامريكي
زين الدين كان واضحا والقياده الامريكيه
كانت ايضا في اوروبا واضحه بان ما ادى الى
سقوط هذه المسيره هو اقتراب احدى
المقاتلتين الروسيتين من طراز سوخوي 27
بشكل غير مهني من
المسيره التحليق امامها اكثر من مره وثم
قامت احدى المقاتلتين بافراغ حموله من
الوقود النفاث فوق المسيره قبل ان تصطدم
بالمروحه الدفع المزوده بها مسيره
في المعلومات اضطرت القوات الجويه
الامريكيه الى انزالها بعد ان بدات بفقدان
السيطره عليها لانها لم تستطع بعد ذلك ان
تتحكم بطيرانها ما ادى الى سقوطها قائد
القوات الجويه الامريكيه في اوروبا
وافريقيا
الجنرال هيكل كان عندما اشار بان الجانب
الروسي انما قامت به المقاتله الروسيه
واصطدامها بالمسيره ادى الى سقوطها تحطمه
تحطمها في البحر الاسود والى فقدانها وهو
اشار الى ان المقاتل الروسيه ايضا تعرضت
لضرر باتريدر ايضا المتحدث باسم كان واضحا
عندما قال بان هناك اصطدام حصل ووفقه
مسؤول في البنطلون هذا الاصطدام ادى الى
الحاق اضرار ربما باحدى المقاتلتين
الروسيتين اللتين حطتان في نهايه المطاف
في شبه جزيره القرم البانتاجون يقول ان
هذه لا يخفي بان هذه طائره تجسس واستطلاع
وجمع معلومات لكن اين كانت تحديدا من ما
يتعلق بالاراضي الروسيه او الاوكرانيه فهو
لم يفصح عن هذه المعطيات الحساسه ولم يحصر
يفصح تحديدا المهمه التي كانت موكله بها
هذه الطائره في ذلك التوقيت تاكيده على
مسالتين اساسيتين المساله الاولى ان هذه
عمليه روتينيه تحصل في الاجواء الدوليه
وبان المسيره سقطت في المياه الدوليه في
البحر الاسود لكن ايضا هناك تاكيد من قبل
وتحذير من قبل القياده الاوروبيه
الامريكيه بان ما حصل هذه الحادثه تندرج
في سياق يتعلق بنمط من التصرفات الخطيره
التي يقوم بها الطيارون الروس وحذرت من ان
الاستمرار في هذه التصرفات قد يؤدي الى
سوء التقدير والتصعيد غير المقصود وفق
بيان مفصل حول هذه الحادثه زين الدين
ابقى معنا اذا فادي منصور من البنترون
نتحول الى مدير مكتب الجزيره في موسكو
زاور شاوش يعني لم يمثل روس تقريبا صور
الاصطدام لكن بقيه ما قاله الامريكيون عن
الاقتراب من المسيره الامريكيه
صب الوقود عليها من قبل احدى المقاتلات
الروسيه هل نفاه الروس ايضا
لم يتطرق له الروس ابدا الروس لهم روايتهم
كما للامريكيين وبالتالي
موسكو قالت على لسان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انه تم اعتراض هذه المسيره التي كانت
تقترب من الاراضي الروسيه في شبه جزيره
القرم وانه نتيجه مناوره خطيره سقطت وصدمت
بالمياه ولكن زين العابدين روسيا هي اكثر
من مناسبه في الاونه الاخيره في الاسابيع
الاخيره كانت تحذر من انها لن تقبل بعد
ذلك ان يتم استخدام الاقمار الاصطناعيه
بما فيها التجاريه والاقمار الصناعيه
العسكريه والطائرات المسيره لحلف شمال
الاطلسي في تقديم المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
وحتى توجيه الصواريخ التي تستهدف منذ
بدايه الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
القطعات العسكريه وحتى قاعده البحر الاسود
في سيف ستوبل روسيا اتهمت الولايات
المتحده وحلف شمال الاطلسي بالمشاركه
المباشره في هذا نزاع عبر تقديم المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه وهذه الطائره هي طائره تجسس
استخباراتها كانت موجوده على مسافه قريبه
بحسب روايه روسيه من شبه جزيره القرم شبه
جزيره القرم التي
يتحدثونها قريبا وسيقوم البناء ويقومون
بعمليه عسكريه لاستعادتها هذه المنطقه
التي يوجد فيها اكبر قاعده لاسطول البحر
الاسود الروسي فيها تجمع عسكري كبير هي
منطقه استراتيجيه بالمعنى العسكري
وبالمعنى السياسي لروسيا وروسيا اليوم في
هذه المناسبه ليست المره الاولى التي
تعطلت فيها طائرات تابعه للولايات المتحده
منذ عام 2018 كما تذكر ربما زين العابدين
كنا نغطي بشكل تقريبا شبه دائم عن
اعتراضات فوق البحر الاسود من قبل طائرات
روسيه لطائرات تابعه لحلف شمال الاطلسي
بريطانيه وامريكيه وفرنسيه وحلف البحر
الاسود اليوم هو فعليا فيه روسيا والدول
تقريبا اربع دول اعضاء في حلف شمال
الاطلسي اضافه الى جورجيا الحليفه لهذا
الحلف واوكرانيا البحر الاسود اليوم ايضا
قضيه اساسيه هو بحر جزء اساسي من النزاع
والحرب الموجوده الان في اوكرانيا
وبالتالي هو اي تواجد عسكري ان كان في
المياه الدولي او قرب شواطئ الروسيه او
قرب منطقه العمليات العسكريه هو يشكل
هاجسا امنيا وتحديا كبيرا بالنسبه لروسيا
التي كما ذكرت انتقدت في اكثر من مناسبه
تقديم الدول الغربيه لمعلومات استخباراتيه
وحتى التوجيه الصواريخ التي تستهدف القوات
الروسيه في اكثر من مناسبه منذ بدايه
الحرب قبل اكثر من عام زي العابدين شكرا
جزيلا لك مكتب الجزيره في موسكو وشكرا
ايضا لفادي منصور من مراسل الجزيره
مسيره ام كيو 9 الامريكيه تمتلك مواصفات
تكنولوجيه عاليه يمكنها القيام باكثر من
مهمه يبلغ طوله الطائره الواحده منها 11
مترا وعرضها عشرون يبلغ عشرين مترا ويبلغ
وزنها فارغه اكثر من طنين وتتميز بقدرتها
على حمل الصواريخ كهل فاير ويمكنها
الطيران لمسافه
1850 كم دون التزود بالوقود هذه المسيره
تمتلك نظام رادار ينقل البيانات لعدد من
الطائرات والمواقع على الارض ويشار الى ان
تقارير فادت باستخدامها في اغتيال قائد
فيلق القدس الايراني قاسم سليماني في
بغداد ولاحقا زعيم تنظيم القاعده ايمن
الظواهر في العاصمه الافغانيه كابول
وينضم الينا من واشنطن لاري كوربا مساعد
وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق وكبير
الباحثين في مركز التقدم الامريكي ومن
موسكوب
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي وابدا
بضيفنا من واشنطن
يعني ما هي قراءتك للبيان الامريكي بيان
الامريكي على ما يدل فيما يتعلق بمهمه هذه
الطائره وما كانت تحمله لانه بحسب بيان
البنتاجون وبيان لوزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
هو ان الجيش الامريكي هو الذي وصل الى
قرار وخلاصه بضروره اسقاطها واسقطها
بالفعل
نحن نعرف ان المسيره كانت
في الاجواء الدوليه هي لما تكون تقوم باي
شيء غير قانوني والطائرات الروسيه اصطدمت
بها وهذا ما سبب لها ان تصطدم وتسقط في
البحر الاسود اعتقد ان البنتاكو كان صريحا
حول ما حدث
واعتقد انه يجب ان يكون هنالك تحقيق بعد
التحقيق سنعرفه حقيقه ما حدث فعلا
لكن طريقه انزالها بهذه الطريقه من قبل
الجيش الامريكي الا يدل على ان انها كانت
تحمل اسلحه على سبيل المثال او الذخيره
يمكن ان
تكون مصدر خطر ومشكله كبيره بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده
اعتقد ان سبب لقيام قيامهم بذلك هو ان
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه التي تم جمعها
وكان هم قلقون من قيام الروس او ربما
اطراف اخرى حول كيفيه قيامنا بجمع
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
واستخلاص هذه المعلومات كانت تلك المسيره
في الاجواء الدوليه وكانت تقوم بجمع
المعلومات حول ما يحدث في المنطقه ونحن
قمنا بهذا الامر منذ سنوات ومن خصائص طبعا
ارسال المعلومات يعني اذا كانت قد جمعت
معلومات فلا بد انها قد ارسلتها
كيف ترى في الروايه الروسيه الروايه
الروسيه التي تتحدث ابدا عن اصطدام لكن
سبق لروسيا ان اعترض الطائرات واعترفت
باعتراض طائرات من قبل
كلا الطرفين وفقاء على ان المقاتلات
الروسيه قامت باعتراضي المسيره الامريكيه
كلا طرفين
قال انه لم يكن هنالك استخدام للقوه
العسكريه لم يتم اطلاق اي نار وقال
الامريكيون انه كان هنالك اصطدام الجيش
الروسي قال لم يكن هنالك مثل هذا التصادم
لكن هذا هو ليس المشكله الحقيقيه فعلا ولا
يئس القضيه الاساسيه هنا القضيه الاساسيه
والاخبار الطيبه في رايي ان هذا هذه هي
ليست البدايه لحرب عالميه ثالثه هي كانت
حادثه عرضيه لم يتم لم يقتل فيه احد وايضا
المسيره
الامريكيه ليست باهضه الثمن
هي ربما اقل ثمن من 15% او عشرين بالمئه
من التي حدث ان اسقطها الايرانيون قبل
سنوات فوق مياه الخليج
وقاموا قمل ايرانيين في وقتها قام
الايرانيون باسقاط هذه المسايره بالشكل
المتعمد هذا ما حصل اليوم كان حادثا
بالتالي هذا يعني انه لن يكون هنالك اي
تصعيد ليس لا يكون هناك عمليات انتقاميه
لكن هذا يظهر ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث اذا
مكانه هنالك خساره للارواح لان
طائرات الامريكيه والبريطانيه وايضا
هنالك ايضا اذا ما كان هنا اول فرنسيه اذا
ما كان هنالك اصطدام وخساره للارواح
فسيكون الامر سيئا للغايه هذه طائره مصيره
غير بدون طيار لكن ضيفنا سيد كورب من من
واشنطن
جونكر بقاله انه اذا كانت هنالك رساله من
اعتراض هذه المسيره الامريكيه من قبل
المقاتلات الروسيه
لثاني الولايات المتحده على التحليق في
البحر الاسود فان هذه الرساله قد فشلت لكن
بالفعل اذا كانت هنالك رساله هل ستتصرف
الولايات المتحده وكانما حدث اليوم لم
يحدث
لا اعتقد انه نقوم بالاحتجاج على ما حدث
لانه في مقام البيه لم يطلقوا النار لكنهم
تصطدموا بها واصابها بعطل وبالتالي كان
هنالك اضطرار لاسقاطها ولا اعتقد انه
سنستمر اعتقد انه سنستمر بالقيام بهذه
المهام لكي نظهر اننا لن نوقف لن نتوقف
ولن تثبت زائمنا من جراء
طيشي الروس بخلاف ما قاله زميلي الذي قال
انه لم يكون هنالك تصعيد كنت اقوم
بالطيران في مهمات عسكريه وكان هنالك عاده
حالات اعتراض وازعاج من قبل الطيران
الروسي كان يقتربون منا بشكل كبير لكنهم
معتادين على القيام بهذه الامور الخطره
الطائشه لا نعرف ما حصل عفوا اليوم كان
بشكل متعمد ام عرضي اعتقد انهم قاموا بذلك
بشكل متعمد لارسال رساله للولايات المتحده
لكي توقف الولايات المتحده هذه المهام
اذا كانت هنالك رساله وتم ايصالها بهذا
الشكل اليوم وهو عدم اطلاق النار حسب
الروايه الروسيه عدم
لمس الطائره الامريكيه هذه الطائره قد
تراها موسكو خطيره لانها تجمع معلومات في
منطقه حرب
مهمه تقول روسنا حرب وجوديه كيف سيكون
التعامل الروسي مستقبلا مع استمرار مثل
هذه المهامله طائرات الاستطلاع الامريكيه
ان البيان الروسي من وزاره الدفاع بشكل
اساسي يذكر انه لم يكن هذا الامر
اصطداما كان حادثا عرضيا انا اعتقد
ان هنالك رغبه لخفض التصعيد لكن اعتقد ان
يعتقدوا ان كلا الطرفين لا يرغبان
بالتصعيد وخروج الامور عن السيطره وهذه
امور طيبه لكن التوتر عالين في المنطقه
وهنالك الكثير من
الاحتمالات انهم مستقبلا قد يكون هنالك
حوادث اسوا من هذه الحادثه التي حصلت
اليوم وقد يؤدي هذا الامر الى تصعيد خطير
لكن
حاليا كلا الطرفين يريدان ان يبقي هذا
الامر تحت السيطره يريدان ان يكون هنالك
ربما احتجاج دبلوماسيه روسيا ستقول انها
لم نقم باي شيء خاطئ وسيكون ربما هذه هذا
نهايه ما لهذه القصه لكن لا نعرف ما سيحدث
مستقبلا
شكرا جزيلا من موسكو بافلجنهاور الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي كما نشكر ضيفنا
بالواشنطن لا ريكورد مساعد وزير الدفاع
الامريكي السابق وكبير الباحثين في مركز
التقدم الامريكي
[موسيقى]
طلعت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قوتها تتقدم
من الجهه الشماليه الغربيه لبخمه بينما
اكد رئيس شركه
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحضر لهجوم المضاد
في المدينه وفي غضون ذلك اعلن الرئيس
الاوكراني
ان اجتماع القيره العليا للجيش اتخذ قرارا
بمواصله الحفاظ على مدينه باخموت وحمايتها
بين تصميم الروس على اخضاعها وقرار
الاوكرانيين بالدفاع عنها حتى الموت اصبحت
معركه باخموت صراع ايرادات حقيقيه اكثر
منها قتالا تقليديا محكوما بميزان القوه
العسكريه في الميدان ومع اقتراب المعارك
من وسط المدينه شبه المدمره لا يفتا
المهاجمون كما المدافعين عنها يتوعدون
بعضهم بعضا بالويلات والعواقب قائد
ميليشيا فاجنر التي تقود الهجوم صرح ان
قواته تقاتل الان بالقرب من مبنى اداره
مدينه باخموت مؤكدا ان حوالي 70 الف عسكري
اوكراني يتمركزون في المدينه ومحيطها وان
كيف تكبدت خلال شهر في مخموت 11 الف قتيل
غير ان الاهم في تصريحات قائد ميليشيا
فاجنر كان حديثه عن استعداد القوات
الاوكرانيه لشن هجوم عاكس يرد مقاتلي
فاغنر على اعقابهم لا يمكن الجزم بصدقيه
تلك المعطيات لكن القياده العسكريه
الاوكرانيه التي اقرت بصعوبات ميدانيه
اعلنت تصدق قواتها لهجمات روسيه في محيط
بخموت من الجهتين الشماليه والغربيه وهي
قبل ذلك كشفت مرارا ان استراتيجيتها تقوم
على التمسك بالمدينه اطول وقت ممكن
لاستنزاف الخصم واضعافه قبل شن هجوم مضاد
تراهن كيف على ان يكون حاسما في الشرق
وتترقب وصول اسلحه غربيه متطوره اليها
قريبا قرار الحفاظ على بخموت اعاده
التاكيد عليه ايضا الرئيس زيلينسكي في
اعقاب اجتماع القياده العليا للجيش
الاوكراني
كنت اليوم على اتصال مع قادتنا المعلومات
الاستخباريه تصف الوضع في الشرق بانه صعب
جدا ومؤلم جدا يجب علينا تد قوه العسكريه
العدو وسوف ندمرها على الجهه المقابله
تمضي البيانات العسكريه والتصريحات
السياسيه في مسار التصعيد ايضا ومن هرم
القياده في موسكو نفترض
الامر ببساطه بالنسبه الينا ليس صراعا من
اجل حاله جيوسياسيه بل هو صراع من اجل
وجود الدوله الروسيه لان خصم او كما كنت
اقول سابقا شركائنا لديهم مهمه واحده خلال
السنوات العشر الماضيه هي الزعزعه
والتقسيم الى اجزاء هذا هو الامر اما وزير
الدفاع الروسي فحرص على زياره احد مصانع
الذخيره في ضواحي موسكو تزامنا مع تقارير
غربيه عن مواجهه الجيش الروسي في اوكرانيا
نقصا في العتاد والذخائر وهو ما ذهبت الى
ترجيحه ايضا الاستخبارات البريطانيه قائله
ان روسيا تستخدم الان ذخيره قديمه لا سيما
لسلاح المدفعيه وهو ما قد يفسر عدم تمكن
اي تشكيل عسكري روسي بخلاف ميليشيايف من
تنفيذ عمل هجومي كبير خلال الفتره الماضيه
وبين موسكو وكيف تجدد التجاذبات بشان
اتفاق الحبوب موسكو اعلنت موافقتها على
تمديده شهرين كبادره حسينيه لكنها رفضت
تمديده الى 120 يوما اذا لم يرفع الحظر عن
صدرتها الزراعيه كيف انتقلت هذه الخطوه
واعتبرت انها تتعارض مع بنود الاتفاق الذي
ينص على ان يكون التمديد لاربعه اشهر
مزاحما اخبار المعارك المستعره في باخموت
يعود اتفاق تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه الى
الواجهه قبل ايام قليله على انتهائه تقول
روسيا انها وافقت كبادره حسن نيه على
تمديد الاتفاق لمده 60 يوما معربه عن
املها في تنفيذ الجزء الثاني من الاتفاق
الذي يتضمن ازاله القيود المفروضه على
تصدير المنتجات الزراعيه الروسيه لكن
اعتبرت من جانبها الخطوه الروسيه متعارضه
مع الاتفاق الذي انجز برعايه تركيا والامم
المتحده فالاصل ان يكون التمديد لمئه
وعشرين يوما في حين اعلن المتحدث باسم
الامم المتحده ووزاره الدفاع التركيه بان
المشاورات بشان تمديد الاتفاق الذي يسمح
بتصدير خمسه ملايين طن من الحبوب شهريا
مستمره مع كل الاطراف
كان التوصل الاتفاق الحبوب نهايه يوليو
الماضي اول خبر سعيد يستقبله العالم متصل
بالحرب التي اندلعت نهايه فبراير 2022
لاسيما وان رحاها تدور بين بلدين يستحوذان
على نحو الثلث صادرات القمح العالميه
فعوده التصدير من موانئ اوكرانيا ساهمت في
وضع حد لتفاقم اعداد الجوعى وللارتفاع
الجنوني الذي طرا على اسعار الغذاء عالميا
لا سيما القمح بسبب الضرر الذي لحق بسلاسل
امداداته اذ شهدت اسعاره ارتفاعا باكثر من
60% بعد نحو ثلاثه اشهر على الحرب فتقدس
القمح في الموانئ الاوكرانيه كان يعني عجز
عشرات الملايين في دول اسيويه وافريقيه عن
الحصول على رغيف الخبز في حين كان الامن
الغذائي للعديد من الدول العربيه الضحيه
الاولى لاندلاع الحرب في ظل استيرادها نحو
60% من احتياجاتها من القمح من روسيا
واوكرانيا ومن بين اكثر الدول تضررا لبنان
ومصر التي تعد اكبر مستورد للقمح في
العالم اضافه الى اليمن وتونس
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه ان الصفقه
الغواصات الامريكيه الاستراليه البريطانيه
تنتهك معاهده عدم انتشار الاسلحه النوويه
واشددت الوزاره رفضه لصفقه الغواصات
الاستراليا واعتباراتها تهديدا للامن
العالمي اكرت الخارجيه الصينيه ضروره
الحفاظ على قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه مع
الجانب الامريكي
هذا وقال الكرملين ان هناك الكثير من
الاسئله بشان مساله عدم انتشار الاسلحه
النوويه في ضوء خطط نقل الغواصات النوويه
الى استراليا واعلن وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
خلال افتتاح المؤتمر التاسيسي لما يسمى
بالحركه الدوليه محبي روسيا ان العالم
الانجلو ساكسوني بانشائه تكتلات على غرار
اوكوس ودفع البنيه التحتيه النيتو الى
اسيا يعد اعلانا جدا
لمواجهه تدوم سنين طويله
العلم
بانشائه تكتلات على غرار اوكوس وتعزيز
البنيه التحتيه العسكريه للنيتو في اسيا
يكشف عن اعلان جاد عن المواجهه لسنوات عده
لانني لا اتخيل كيف يمكن سحب الحضارات
الاسيويه العظمى تحتى مظلتهم كما وللاسف
تم سحب الاتحاد الاوروبي لينفذوا
خطط واشنطن وزملائها الانجلوس ساكسونيين
نحن لا نحاول ردع اي كان عن تحقيق مصالحه
الشرعيه عندما يصرحون بضروره اخضاع العالم
باجمعه لحلف شمال الاطلسي على سبيل المثال
وكان الرئيس الامريكي قد عقد اجتماعا
ثلاثيا مع رئيس هي الوزراء الاسرائيلي
والبريطاني في قاعده
البحريه في سانديرو ويرمي هذا الاجتماع
لوضع اللمسات الاخيره على اتفاقيه اتفاقيه
تزود بموجبها الولايات المتحده استراليا
بغواصات تعمل بالطاقه النوويه وذلك
استنادا لاتفاقيه ثلاثيه بينهم وقال بيض
ان الغواصات التي سيتم تزويد استراليا بها
ليست اسلحه ثانويه بل هي غواصات تعمل
بالطاقه النوويه
نعلن عن الخطوات اللازمه لتنفيذ مشروعنا
الاول في اطار اتفاقيه اوكوس لتطوير
القدرات الاستراليه في مجال الغواصات
المسلحه التقليديا والتي تعمل بطاقه نوويه
ولكنها لا تحمل اسلحه ذريه فاستراليا دوله
تفتخر بانها غير نوويه وهي ملتزمه بالبقاء
على هذا النحو
وتاتي اهميه هذه الغواصات العامله بالدفع
النوويه لاعتبارات عديده اهمها طريقه
تزودها بالطاقه والتنوع ادوارها لكن اخطر
الغواصات هي تلك التي يمكنها اطلاق
الصواريخ باليسيه تحمل رؤوساويه ونتعرف
على خصائص الغواصات ذات الدفع النووي
والفوارق بينها وبين الغواصات التقليديه
في هذا التقرير
وتشغيل السفن والغواصات بدفع النووي اي
الوقود النووي بدل الوقود التقليدي الى
اربعينيه القرن الماضي حيث انتجت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اول غواصه نوويه عام 54
وعرفت باسم نوتيلا لتصبح اول غواصه تصل
الى القطب الشمالي عام 58 تمتلك الان ست
دول غواصه نوويه هي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وروسيا وفرنسا والمملكه المتحده
والصين والهند تختلف الغواصات العامله
بالدفع النووي عن الغواصه التقليديه في
طريقه تزودها بالطاقه فهي لا تتطلب التزود
بالوقود تمكنها الكفاءه العاليه للطاقه
النوويه من العمل بسرعه عاليه لفتره اطول
حينما تزود بكميات من وقود اليورانيوم
تكفيها للعمل مده تزيد على 30 عاما وعلى
عكس احتراق الوقود التقليدي لا تتطلب
المفاعلات النوويه هواء وهذا يعني ان
الغواصه النوويه يمكن ان تبقى في اعماق
المحيطات عده اشهر بحاجه للظهور الى السطح
الجانب السلبي يبقى تكلفتها العاليه بعده
مليارات من الدولارات والحاجه الى عاملين
مختصين في مسائل التشغيل النووي اضافه الى
خطر حدوث تسرب اشعاعي او تعطل جهاز تبريد
المفاعل العامل البشري يحدد بقائها في
البحر فلابد بين حين واخر من تعبئه وتموين
جديد
لاطعام طاقم الغواصه توجد على متنها اجهزه
لاعاده تدوير وتنظيف الهواء كما تسحب
الغواصه النوويه مياه البحر وتنقيها عبر
عمليه تحليه للمياه يستخدم بعضها للشرب
ايضا تقوم الغواصات العامله بدفع النووي
بمجموعه كبيره من المهام في المحيطات
الكبرى وقرب السواحل ولها قدره على جمع
المعلومات والتجسس وخوض الحروب المضاده
للغواصات
وتم تحديد ثلاثه اصناف للغواصات النوويه
فبينها ما تقوم بعمليه الاستطلاع وانزال
قوه خاصه واخرى تقوم بالهجوم التكتيكي على
حاملات طائره العدو ومواقعه البريه لكن
الاخطر والاكثر اثاره للرعب هو النوع الذي
يحمل صواريخ بعضها مزود برؤوس نوويه وعاده
ما تبحر متخفيه لمسافات طويله في المحيطات
في اطار توازنات الرضع حتى الان
[موسيقى]
وفي فقره المتابعه سنسلط بالضوء على
الصراع في منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ
ونستمع الى وجهتي نظر من واشنطن وبيجين
حول صفقه الغواصات وتداعيتها
الان الى باكستان وكاله رويترز نقلت عن
وزير الداخليه الباكستاني ان الشرطه
ستعتقل اليوم رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران
خان وستقدمه للعداله وقد تجمع انصاره خان
امام منزله بعد وصول الفريق من الشرطه
الاعتقاله وذلك بناء على امر قضائي ونقل
مراسل الجزيره عن مسؤول الحكوميه ان
التدافع بدا حين اعترض مؤيد خان رجال شرطه
كانوا يحاولون تسليمه مذكره جلب لحضور
جلسه استماع في المحكمه وقد طلب عمران خان
من انصاره مواصله التظاهر لما سماه نيل
الحريه والاستقلال حتى لو تم اعتقاله
سحابه كثيفه تلك التي تخيم على باكستان
هنا في لاهور عاصمه اقليم البنجاب بلغ
التلوث مستويات قياسيه لكن ليس هذا ما
يشغل بال سكانها
هذه المدينه هي معقل رئيس الوزراء السابق
عمران خان وفيها يتحصن يقول الرجل انه
ضحيه حمله ملاحقه من طرف الدوله العميقه
في باكستان يحاكم عمران خان في 36 قضيه في
مختلف المحاكم الباكستانيه ويرفض المثوله
للمحاكمه في تاريخ باكستان ومنذ تاسيسها
قبل 75 عاما لم يسبق لرئيس حكومه ان تحدى
السلطه كما يفعل عمران خان مستقويا
بانصاره الذين يقدرون بمئات الالاف في
البنجاب وبالملايين في مختلف ولايه
باكستان يتحدى لاعب الكركيت السابق
المنظومه الحاكمه في البلاد ويتهمها
بالانقلاب عليه وهو المنتخب بشكل مباشر من
الشعب ويتهم اطرافا فيها بالوقوف وراء
محاوله اغتياله التي نجى منها في الثالث
من نوفمبر الماضي في خطاباته يقول ان
خصومه يسعون للانتقان منه بسبب اصلاحاته
التي بداها اثناء رئاسته للحكومه
تحديده مراكز السلطه والمال في باكستان
بالمقابل تتهم السلطات الحاكمه في اسلام
اباد من الدروع في قضايا فساد على راسها
عدم الكشف عن اصولنا لها بعد بيع هدايا
حكوميه تلقاها عندما كان على راس السلطه
تاتي هذه التطورات اسابيع قليله قبل
انتخابات ستجرى في اقليم البنجاب الشهر
المقبل في وقت تستمر فيه حاله التوتر في
الاقليم بعد خروج عشرات الالاف من انصار
عمران خان في مظاهرات مؤيده له واعتصام
الالاف امام مقر اقامته لمنع الشرطه من
اعتقاله وتحرج هذه التطورات الحكومه
المركزيه في اسلام اباد التي تعيش تحت
ضغوط داخليه وخارجيه الحاله التي خلق
عمران خان ومعه انصاره فاقمت حاله
الانقسام في البلاد يضاف الى هذا ترد
الاوضاع الاجتماعيه وفشل الحكومه في تحقيق
وعودها بتسريع النمو الاقتصادي واخراج
البلاد من ازمتها فالتضخم في ارتفاع
والنمو في تراجع واحتياط ات النقد الاجنبي
تتضائل وما كانت تعول عليه الحكومه من
اتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدولي لتعزيز
احتياطاتها النقديه لم يتم الاتفاق عليه
بعد
ولا يبدو ان اعتقال رئيس الوزراء السابق
سيعجل حل هذه الاشكالات بل سيزيد من حدتها
بعدما طالب عمران خان انصاره بالاستمرار
فيما وصفه بالكفاح وهو ما يعني استمرار
الازمه وتفاقم تداعياتها وتعميق حاله
الانقسام
هي مزيد من الاخبار عن العالم من شبه
الجزيره الكوريه نقلت رويترز عن الجيش
الكوري الجنوبي اعلانه ان كوريا الشماليه
اطلقت صاروخين لبالستيين قصيرين مدى قباله
ساحلها الشرقيه اليوم في تجربه هي الثانيه
في اقل من ثلاثه ايام ونقلت رويترز عن
بيان للجيش الكوري الجنوبي قوله انها
تكرار كوريا الشماليه اطلاق الصواريخ فعلا
استفزازيب يهدد السلامه والامن في المنطقه
واضافت هيئه الاركان في بيان ان الجيش
الكوري الجنوبي في حاله تاهب عاليه بتنسيق
وثيق مع الولايات المتحده
كما اكد بيان الجيش الكوري الجنوبي ان
التدريبات المشتركه مع الولايات المتحده
مستمره مثل ما هو مخطط اللعب وست تحافظ
على جاهزيه جاهزيه قوامها قدرات ماحقه وفق
تعبير البيان ويشار الى ان الجيشين الكوري
الجنوبيه والامريكيه بدا يوم امس الاثنين
تدريبات مشتركه تعد الاكبر من نوعها ونقلت
رويترز عن بيان للجيشين الامريكي للجيش
الامريكي ان اطلاقها كوريا الشماليه
صاروخين بارسيين لا يشكل تهديدا فوريا لها
او لحلفائها
ومن ناحيه ثانيه قلم مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكيه جيكسون تعليقا على ما تردد عن
اطلاق كوريا الشماليه صواريخ باليستيه من
غواصات قال ان واشنطن تدرس الموقف وتجري
تقييما بشان دلالات هذا التطور ولفت
سولفان الى ان بلاده لن تسمح لاي خطوات
تتخذها كوريا الشماليه برضعها او تقييدها
عن الاجراءات التي تشعر بانها ضروريه
لحمايه الاستقرار في شبه جزيره الكوريه
في اليابان قال المتحدث باسم الحكومه
اليابانيه ان كوريا الشماليه قد تقدم على
مزيد من الاستفزازات في الايام المقبله من
خلال تكثيف التجارب الصاروخيه والنوويه
قباله السواحلها الشرقيه واضاف هيروكازو
ماتسونو ان طوكيو ستواصل التعاون عن كسب
المعلولات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه وبذل
اقصى جهد للبقاء في حاله تاهب ومتابعه
لاتخاذ جميع التدابير الممكنه من اجل
السلام
قال البيت الابيض من شركه
ابرمت صفقتين وصفهما بالتاريخيتين مع شركه
الخطوط السعوديه وطيران الرياض لشراء 111
طائره ركاب من طراز بوينج 787 جيم لاينر
بقيمه سبعه وثلاثين مليار دولار
صندوق الاستثمارات العامه السعوديه ان
عمليه التسليم الطائرات ستبدا اوائل عام
2025 وان الصفقه تدعم هدف الدوله في خدمه
330 مليون راكب بحلول عام 2030 كما توقع
الصندوق ان تضيف الصفقه عشرين مليار دولار
الى اجمالي الناتج المحلي غير النفطيه
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
ووصفت السفاره السعوديه صفقه شراء طائرات
بوينج بانها دليل اخر على متانه العلاقات
التجاريه بين المملكه والولايات المتحده
الى لبنان وقد هوت الليره اللبنانيه امام
الدولار الامريكيه الى مستوى قياسي جديد
بلغ سعره صرف الدولار مئه الف ليره في
السوق الموازيه بينما يبلغ السعر الرسمي
خمسه عشر الف ليره مقابل الدولار الواحد
وقد حدد مصرف لبنان سعر الاضافيا لصرف
الدولار في المداولات التجاريه عبر منصه
صيرفه يبلغ نحو 75 الف ليره وياتي انهيار
الليره في ظل الازمه الاقتصاديه التي بدات
منتصف عام 2019 وحولت اكثر من 80% من
اللبنانيين الى فقراء وفق منظمه تلسكوا
اذا وبعد ثلاث سنوات ونصف منذ بدايه
الازمه اللبنانيه باتت المئه الف ليره هي
اكبر ورقه نقديه موجوده في السوق الماليه
اللبنانيه تساوي دولارا واحدا فقط نستعرض
في التقرير التالي ابرز محطات تدهور
العمله اللبنانيه
خسرت العمله اللبنانيه 98% من قيمتها منذ
بدء الانهيار الاقتصادي في خريف 2019 حيث
اندلعت انتفاضه شعبيه لبنانيه عابره
للمناطق احتجاجا على ترد الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وفي الرابع من
اغسطس عام 2020 تسبب انفجار مرفا بيروت في
عواقب اقتصاديه كبيره واقترب سعر الصرف من
9000 ليره وفي يونيو عام 2021 صنف البنك
الدولي ازمه لبنان الاقتصاديه بين الاشد
حده في العالم منذ منتصف القرن التاسع عشر
وتجاوز سعر الصرف حاجز العشرين الف ليره
واستمرت اللبنانيه في خساره قيمتها لتتخطى
في فبراير الماضي عتبه 80 الف ليره
لبنانيه مقابل الدولار
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نعود من جديد الى الشراكه
التاريخيه بين الولايات المتحده واستراليا
والمملكه المتحده في برنامج الغواصات
العامله بالدفع النووي هي شراكه اعادت الى
الواجهه الصراعه في منطقه المحيطين الهندي
والهادئ والتي تشهد نشاطا عسكريا ومنافسه
جيوسيه الى المحيطين الهندي والهادئ اذا
تتجه
اساطير بحريه واسراب جويه اوحدتهم بريه من
الشرق والغرب في تنافس قوي بين محور الصين
وروسيا من جهه ومحور الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها من الجهه الاخرى في هذه المنطقه
طورت الولايات المتحده تدريجيا تحالفات مع
اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه والهند واستراليا
وشركاء اخرين بغيه مواجهه اي او احتواء
الصين في الواقع
اوساط غربيه وامريكيه بالتحديد تحذر من ان
منطقه جنوب المحيط الهادئ اصبحت ملعب
الصين الجديد عسكريا واقتصاديا وسياسيا من
بيجين وتحديدا الاسبوع الماضي اتهم الرئيس
الصيني واشنطن بقياده الجهود الغربيه
باتجاه الى احتواء والتطويق والكبت الكامل
للصين كما قال
ورغبه منها في مواجهه نفوذ الصين في
المحيط الهادئ اطلقت واشنطن
ولندن وكامبرا تحالفها المعروف باسم معلنه
عن شراكه لصنع جيل الجديد من الغواصات
النوويه بعد شراء كاميرا المرتقب لعدد من
الغواصات فماذا في التفاصيل في هذا
الاتفاق ومن يقرر هذا الاتفاعه المتحده
لاستراليا ثلاثه غواصات امريكيه تعمل
بالطاقه النوويه من فئه فيرجينيا في اول
العقد الثالث من القرن الحالي طبعا اللي
هو العقد المقبل مع شراء مع امكانيه شراء
غواصتين اخريين اذا لزم الامر
هذا المشروع المتعدد المراحل سيتوج بانتاج
بريطانيا واستراليا
وتشغيلهما فئه جديده من الغواصات من طراز
اس اس ام او نتحدث عن غواصه من
تطوير الاطراف الثلاثه تعتمد على تصميمات
الجيل التالي البريطانيه وسيتم انتاجها في
بريطانيا واستراليا مع تزويدها طبعا
بتقنيات امريكيه بريطانيا ستتسلم اول
غواصه
في اواخر العقد الثالث من القرن الحالي
وهو ايضا العقد المقبل في حين تتسلم
استراليا اولى غواصاتها في اوائل العقد
الرابع الصين هي الجهه الاخرى ندلت بمشروع
عوقف قالت انه عمل غير قانوني لنشر السلاح
النووي وقال الكلام كذلك ان الاتفاق يثير
تساؤلات حول الانتشار النووي
حول هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن وليم كيجن
مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق لشؤون
الترسانه النوويه ومدير
الاختبار والتقييم لبرنامج الغواصات
الاستراتيجيه سابقا هذا من واشنطن ومعنا
من بيجين رونج روان الاعلامي والباحث
السياسي وابدا بضيفنا من بيجين رونج وان
الصين والولايات وروسيا اعتبرت صفقه
الغواصات التي لم تسلم بعد في الواقع
ستسلم في غضون سنوات اعتبرتها مخالفه
لمعاهده الانتشار النووي مع ان الغواصات
لن تحمل اي اسلحه نوويه كيف لماذا
اهلا ومرحبا بكم
نعم هذا اولا هذا
[موسيقى]
التعاونه يعني مهما كانت يعني حوجاتها
الوضع هو ان
هو انه اول مره لنقل المواد النوويه
يعني
يرايون العاليه
اسلحه النوويه الى
من دوله
تملك الاسلحه النوويه الى دوله خاليه من
اي مواد النوويه سابقا فهذا ايضا هذه اول
مره وكذلك يعني يزيد خطرا على الانتشار
النووي عرفنا انه يعني ان الدول الثلاثه
تقول انه ليس اسلحه نوويه
نقلا من
المواد النوويه او تقنيه النموذيه من يعني
دوله
تمتلك اسلحه نوويه الى المناطق
بمنطقه او دوله النخاليه تماما من المواد
النووي وهل وعاده الانتشار النووي تشمل
الانتقال السلمي
للتكنولوجيا والتقنيه النوويه طالما ان
الموضوع ليس فيه سلاح اين هو
المخالفه لمعالجه انتشار النووي
نعم هناك كما قلت زياده احتمال
حدوث يعني
[موسيقى]
المواد النوويه ايضا هو يعني قابل
لنقل الاسلحه
لصناعه اسلحه النوويه
فيمكن ان نرى الولايات المتحده تاخذ
العقوبات على ايران
وكوريا الشماليه لانه يعني
بتدوير الاسلحه النوويه ولكن حاليا هم
كذلك لم تمتلك الاسلحه النوويه والنموات
النوويه فقط ويليام هذه الغواصه او هذه
الصفقه صفقه اوكوس
ما الذي ستضيفه للبنيه العسكريه للولايات
المتحده وحلفائها لانه هنالك غواصات
امريكيه وغواصات بريطانيه وغوصت فرنسيه
موجوده في
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها تعمل ايضا
بالطاقه النوويه موجوده في كثير من
المناطق العالم ولعلها في هذه المنطقه فما
الذي ستضيفه هذه الغواصات وهذه الصفقه
للبنيه التي تسعى الولايات المتحده
لقيمتها في المحيط هذا الهندي والهادئ
لمواجهه الص
شكرا على الاستضافه الغرض من وجود اسطول
للغواصات التي تعمل بالطاقه النوويه هي
تلبيه احتياجات الدفاعيه لاستراليه وهي
حليفه للولايات المتحده كان هنالك الكثير
من الحديث من السيد الضيف الاخر عن مساله
تصنيع الاسلحه النوويه القوه النوويه ليست
خرقا على الاطلاق وفي حقيقه الامر فان رد
فعل الحكومه الاستراليه والولايات المتحده
والمملكه المتحده هو كان هنالك اتفاق على
توفير دفاعات كافيه
لتهديدات
الاسطول الصيني العسكري الذي هو اصبح الان
الاكبر في العالم
مره اخرى الى رونج يعني هل قلق الصين من
هذه الغواصات طبعا ليس فقط على الانتشار
النووي ما التهديد الذي تمثله هذه
الغواصات ووجود بنيه اساسيه نوويه حتى وان
قيل انها ليست لا تحمل رؤوس النوويه ما
الذي يهدد الصين في وجود مثل هذه الغواصات
في حول استراليا
نعم لان هذه
الغواصات ايضا تحميل
الهجوميه وكذلك
هو الايسم لاجل السلام بل من اجل احتواء
الصين من ضمن البرنامج الولايات المتحده
الاحتواء الصين وهذا ايضا ايها الزيت يعني
السباكه تسلح في هذه المنطقه وكذلك يزيد
المخاطر المواجهه في هذه المنطقه ولذلك
لان السن تعتبر منطقه اسيا هي منطقه اكثر
حاجبيه او اكثر اكثر امكانيه لتنميه
الاقتصاديه والازدهار وليس
يعني
المنافسه الجنسيه السياسيه
والتخصصي ايضا عن الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
وهذا نقطه
الوزير الخارجيه الروسي وهو نقل بنيه
الناتو الى اسيا هذا هذا التمدد لما وصفه
بالقوات او القوه الانجلوساكسونيه في
المحيط الهادي والمحيط الهندي ونقل البنيه
التحتيه الى اسيا لابد ان تقول له عواقب
ما هي العواقب المتوقعه من وجهه نظركم
طبعا هذا السؤال يمكن ان نرى
اوكي تمام تفضل
لن يكون هنالك سبب لاحتواء الصين اعتقد ان
الصين عليها ان تقوم بمعرفه الاسباب التي
توجب احتوائها الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
وكل الدول التي تبحث
لتحقيق السلام هي والحفاظ على النظام
الدولي المشكله الان ان هنالك اسطول بحري
صيني اعدائي هو هنالك سياسه خارجيه واضحه
وتصمم وكما راينا على ان تقوم بوضع الجزر
بالقرب من ساحل الفلبين والفيتنام والتي
هي اقرب الى تلك الدول وهذا بالتاكيد يقوم
بتخويفي الاطراف والدول الاخرى في المنطقه
ويهدد حريه
الابحار والتجاره وهذه هي الاولويه وهذا
هو النظام الدولي الذي يحتاجه العالم وليس
هنالك اي سبب لا يمكن للصين ان تكون تتمتع
برفاهيه ضمن هذا النظام
منا واشنطن ويليام شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا
لرونكوان من
[موسيقى]
هي من تدفع اغلى ثمن هذا هو عنوان تقرير
يذكرنا بضحايا النزاعات تقرير يسلط الضوء
على تاثير الصراعي على خدمات الصحه التي
تحتاجها الفتيات والنساء في شمال غربي
سوريا هذا التقرير صدر عن اطباء من اجل
حقوق الانسان ولجنه الانقاذ الدوليه
وسوريا للغاثه والتنميه والجمعيه الطبيه
السوريه الامريكيه يتوقع التقرير ان تؤثر
الزياره الكبيره في النزوح وتدمير الطرق
ونقص الوقود ومحدوديه الخدمات الصحيه
والادويه والمعدات الطبيه على قرابه
1848 الف امراه حامل في شمال غرب سوريا
ينتظر ان تلد 73
الفا منهن في الاشهر الثلاثه المقبله
الخدمات الصحيه من حقوق الانسان الاساسيه
لكنه كما يقول التقرير تنتهكوا باستمرار
في شمال غرب سوريا حيث تنزل القنابل
كالمطر على المستشفيات ويتعرض العاملون
الصحيون بالاطحاط كان الله في عون الجميع
شكرا لكم وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]